il était une fois il était une fois un
très grand désir de venir flâner en
forêt de brocéliande
c'était le mien sans doute me futile
communiqué par une grand-mère de
quelneuc non loin d'ici elle même
inspirée par peut-être iso la blonde les
fées mélusine morgan viviane par merlin
l'enchanteur par le souffle des druides
par les elfes et des korrigans
sans oublier les évangiles et la parole
du recteur ainsi va la tradition orale
en bretagne et ce sera le centre de
cette émission avec l'un de ses
meilleurs représentants pierre-jakez
hélias dans cette forêt de paimpont la
légende des chevaliers de la table ronde
est présente à chaque pas est par
exemple au château de comper qui est
devenu le centre de l'imaginaire
arthurien et qui est animé par claudine
glot que nous verrons au cours de cette
émission mais nous avons d'autres
traditions à honorer et ceci à moins
d'une semaine des longues nuits du
solstice d'hiver début de la nuit de
noël la plus longue de l'année
et bien sûr nous le ferons avec des
conteurs ont dit que la télévision a tué
le compte est ce que c'est vrai eh bien
nous nous allons ranimer les veillées et
nous allons commencer par vous mettre en
appétit de noël avec pierre jakez hélias
autrefois était autrefois et aujourd'hui
c'est un autre temps dans mon jardin
j'ai un arbre de pommes qui produit des
fruits plus tendre que le pain mais pour
manger ce pain de pommes il faut vous
asseoir dessous l'arbre avec dans la
main dessous de sagesse un grand sac
vide sous la tête pour amasser tous ceux
qui tombent
moi je le dis ma récolte est fait et
mons a tout plein de merveilles que je
dispense acquis les voeux et coûteux et
vous entendrez les sourds des deux
tympans montreront le lieu aux absents
et les aveugles des deux yeux feront
voir le double boiteux l'endroit où
s'est passé le jeu les chine de l'année
pour le bas qui sur le chien ne
tiendrait pas c'est un conte
extraordinaire sang froid pluvieux que
père et mère mais il faut sceller votre
chien si vous voulez comprendre bien et
dans tout ce que je vais vous dire il
n'y a rien de fou sinon peut-être un ou
deux mots pas moi je n'aime que la
vérité quand on ne dit pas vrai
alors on ment ça n'est pas sang froid le
jour mais souvent panel avoir induit
retraire groupe new yorkais de contrôle
mais douce penda où il y avait une fois
et revêche et voix et cette fois là il
n'y avait pas et pourtant quelqu'un m'a
dit qu'il y avait quand même c'était
parti bon c lients des le lieu
symbolique des aventures et des charmes
aussi des chevaliers de la table ronde
mais en fait le territoire du roi arthur
et de sécateurs du saint graal c'est
aussi bien l'angleterre que l'irlande ou
l'armorique
mais c'est ici en brocéliande que la
tradition a pris ses repères et c'est
aussi bien le château de comper là où
nous sommes que là où morgan emprisonna
lancelot du lac et que viviane
emprisonna merlin c'est curieux
d'ailleurs de voir à quel point les
femmes ont joué un grand rôle dans cette
tradition
claudine glot vous connaissez par coeur
vous histoire des chevaliers de la table
ronde
je ne sais pas si je la connais par
coeur je je je crois que j'avance tout
le temps dans cette histoire c'est
tellement vaste et tellement de
réécriture de réinvestissement depuis il
y a le xiième siècle français bon c'est
notre repère à nous parce que c'est
facile mais ce qui est fascinant c'est
tout ce qui est avant tout ce tout ce
toute cette imagination tout cette
méthodologie toute cette religion parce
que il y a quelque chose d'infiniment
religieux aussi dans cette matière là ce
donc un territoire de spiritualité ici
oui ces corps mais ou encore maintenant
encore maintenant dans le courant des
nouvelles spiritualités dans un courant
plus anciens aussi puisqu'à tout le côté
chrétien de la légende depuis
l'humiliation
tout est ancrée autour de ce mât triarc
à celtic non on pourrait dire oui oui
parce que je m'adresse à une femme en
défense car sinon je vais essayer de ne
pas faire un grand numéro de féminisme
celto mais en fait c'est vrai que le
chevalier c'est la brillance et les
classes et l'action mais derrière il ya
toujours ces personnages féminins
j'aurais même envie de dire ce
personnage féminin parce que vous avez
parlé de morgane de viviane et n'a une
autre la maltraiter ses guenièvre
oui coignières qu'on ne comprend plus du
tout parce qu'elle a été passé à la
moulinette d'une autre idéologie d'un
autre repaissent engine de quilles st
c'est la reine c'est la femme d'arthur
mais c'est la souveraineté en fait à
l'intronisent celui qu'elle aime et
quand elle aime lancelot lensois va
devenir le meilleur chevalier et il faut
prendre les trois femmes et en fait ça
fait un modèle féminin
le modèle celtique femina les trois
visages la sorcière la devineresse la
bonne fée des eaux qui serait viviane et
puis la reine
vous faites partie alors soyons revenons
terre à terre enfin ils ont cette viande
vous faites partie d'un certain d'un
syndicat intercommunal des spas et vous
l assurer un peu le développement je
m'occupe des mesures et de cette région
je m'occupe de deux choses voilà d'un
développement touristique de cette
région et c'est vrai que c'est très
délicat parce qu on est tout le temps
justement sur le fil du rasoir entre
cette tendance trop plongé dans les
nouvelles spiritualités qui à mon avis
est une erreur parce que le lieu à une
telle charge de merveilleux que ans sur
ajouté c'est dommage est ce suffisant
il se suffit à soi même je veux dire qu
on le détruit plus tôt en ajoutant des
choses qui sont un petit peu comme les
effets spéciaux dans les films
américains vous savez il tue le
merveilleux plus qu'ils ne le font
naître il ya ce fonds se penchant là bon
je crois il faut tenir compte mais avec
un certain recul
et puis il ya d'autre part un certain
affairisme qui veut qu'il faille
toujours aller en avant que tout lieu
touristique doit être poussé à son
maximum avec un vocabulaire
technocratique assez effrayant et qui
peut tout aussi bien tuer mais l'art
tuer définitivement défiguré un site est
défigurée son esprit aussi ma chambre de
viviane c'est un endroit sûrement très
visitée là on est en plein hiver entouré
brume épaisse la brume participe du
charme du lieu lui la maison de viviane
cesser tout brocéliande
c'est brocéliande parce qu'elle ya le la
préhistoire les hommes de la préhistoire
et leurs rêves
il y a les droïdes parce que ça
s'appelle aussi le tombeau des druides
cet endroit là il y a les druides avec
ce mystère qui reste planer autour d'eux
et puis il y à la légende il ya viviane
7 viviane qui amante de merlin aimé de
lui fini par obtenir cette ultime secret
qui va lui permettre d'en fermer à
jamais l'enchanteur en brocéliande
devant brocéliande en fait moi moi mon
sentiment profond celle
le lien le lien à travers le temps je
parlais de la préhistoire et c'est vrai
que ces lieux ont tellement été habité
réhabitée son porteur de tant d'espoirs
de tant de rêves que ça devient vraiment
tangible
je ne peux pas vous le prouver c'est pas
une chose de faire toucher c'est un
monument dans le sang mais on le sent on
le sent et on leur vie à chaque instant
et dans le réanime et ça je pense que
c'est la chose la plus forte quand on
est là ils ont aboli le temps à
brocéliande
on traverse traversé un petit peu le
miroir on traverse l'horloge on dépasse
tout ça finalement c'est ça qu'il faut
souhaiter qu'il faut transmettre parce
que si on ne transmet pas ça ne sert
plus à rien tous conviés tout ce qu'on
fait on nous l'a transmis temps qu'il
faut à notre tour passer les choses
merci glos alors john boorman qui est à
cinéaste anglais qui beaucoup travaillé
sur le thème des liens entre l'homme et
la nature ces passionnés aussi pour
l'histoire celtique et bien sûr c'est
pour ça qu'il a fait excalibur et serge
irene a rencontré l'année dernière sur
ce thème là
[Applaudissements]
comme steve jobs
je me nomme est le match d'auxerre était
aimée du
[Musique]
en se promenant sous la pluie sur cette
terre de légendes de la forêt de
brocéliande on pourrait parfaitement
imaginer que l'esp et excalibur dont on
vient de parler et pu être forgé ici aux
forges de paimpont
pourquoi pas puisque il y avait du
minerai de fer ici il y avait la forêt
il y avait le fer et le feu et les
chevaliers du 12e siècle travaillaient
les épées peut-être et plus avant au 1er
siècle avant jésus-christ on a retrouvé
des vestiges du travail du fer ça nous
ramène à gilles servat gilles servat est
allé à dublin et nourri des légendes
arthuriennes dont il a fait parfois des
chansons de combat et il a composé une
chanson sur dublin j'ai servent à
toujours travailler des épées mais des
épées de ses cordes les cordes de sa
guitare et voici sa chanson maintenant
heures de glace et je marche est en tiff
regardons les mouettes fille quitté
l'appui des fenêtres en déchirant décrit
brusque ou bien planant peine
tournant le
leurs têtes lançait bell ont pris lundi
jusqu'au mouvance du ciel
[Musique]
m
c'est les trois tracés des ailes sombres
de siph sur des lacs
206 chine sur les briques de la rue et
réunion
dans la falaise un flat inversée de nos
âges rapide
est rempli de plus
trempez de lumière pour ton
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'était pendant l'heure de grâce
et puis claire ivresse j'attendais au
bord du monde
que des qui s'ouvre est encore lancé
par la main d'angus
comme un caillou
qui ricochent à défaut de noir qui n'est
jamais sans mais la ville est plus sous
m
un attelage gris et rose qu'on méritait
sûrement vers le paradis des dom
dans la brume et la rose y est sous sol
agenouillé
oui appuyé sur des grilles dans la joie
by md pop art et aux rôles
l'émeraude rousse défi c'est pas son
récit il est sourire boue et les choses
et passeur d'éternité sous le soleil et
la vie
les champs
feu dans sa team des colonnes pour
de trinité d'arc en ciel
à
[Applaudissements]
et je marche dans dublin sans savoir
vers le nord de l'autre côté m'attendais
un chien moi j'allais vers la grande
poste et je française à des packs en
sifflant
un temps les proches
une musique irlandaise
[Applaudissements]
jusqu'ici pierre jakez hélias vous nous
avez accompagné dans notre fonderie
discrètement vous avez subi comme nous
le brouillard sur brocéliande et la
pluie et alors là je peux témoigner que
vous êtes vraiment un homme de la nature
oui je crois volontiers c'est là que je
me trouve au mieux de ma personne si
j'ose dire je me trouve enfermé dans les
villes
et pourtant bon le métier de conteur si
j'ose dire on peut appeler ses amitiés
c'est quelque chose qui se fait dans des
lieux fermés au coin du feu
oui oui mais alors en voyage avec sa
tête magazine est des quantités de
choses
et lorsque l'on est dans la nature en
général c'est le cas de ce que j'ai
connu les compteurs que j'ai connu en
général c'est la solitude qu'ils aiment
bien
après quoi il ressort ramasse et puis il
se donne se communique avec les autres
justement dans cette veillée qui est un
lieu clos vous êtes compteur vous avez t
home de radio homme de télévision
vous êtes romancier vous venez d'écrire
un roman vous êtes faut être vous êtes
quêteurs de mémoire surtout ça vous a
écrit un livre là-dessus après le cheval
d'orgueil c'est le quêteur neuner
1 est ce qu il ya encore des choses à
quêter en bretagne
oui bien sûr oui oui mais évidemment
c'est très dispersé m'attend et puis la
mémoire a des trous lorsque j'étais
jeune que je suis mon grand père que je
suivais les chiffonniers dollar et que
j'allais interrogé un peu tout le monde
les gens connaissaient encore par
exemple des légendes et des comptes mais
tout du long avec les formules initial
les formules final tous les épisodes qui
arrive est dedans
tandis que maintenant enfin lorsque
j'étais sur la route pour la radio après
45 là je trouvais un épisode par ci un
épisode par là il sait pas ce qu'il y
avait avant ne savait pas si à la fin si
bien que c'était comme on dit en latin
t20 voix directeur enfin des bourses ou
et moi je savais à peu près comment
était construit un compte
quand j'avais trouvé à droite à gauche
au centre-ville yeux j'avais trouvé des
morceaux comme ça j'estimais que j'avais
à peu près le corps entier du compte
alors ce moment là je l'écrivais
pierre-jakez hélias vous avez fait des
émules y ait beaucoup de jeunes par
exemple qui s'intéressent à collecter
des des bribes de mémoire des chansons
et ses 2 par exemple chez ces dastugue
mairie qui font un travail extrêmement
précieux est absolument nécessaire parce
que la mémoire est en train de s'en
aller avec les vieilles générations et
ses vieilles générations nous ont servi
depuis une quarantaine d'années a incité
les jeunes à retrouver leur leurs
sources
pour donner un exemple nous sommes
partis en quarante huit avec à peu près
une dizaine de béziers où ils sont cent
mille vingt ans j'ai commencé par faire
des chansons en breton j'ai écrit des
textes des livrets pour une cantate un
oratorio une opérette parce que le le
théâtre et la chanson c'est encore orale
c'est ça le théâtre après c'est pareil
j'ai écrit beaucoup de pièces de théâtre
président des mauvaises et quelques
domaines mais peut-être même meilleur
enfin dit non mais petit à petit comme
ça petit à petit parce que le théâtre
aussi et aura le tfc la parole et puis
ensuite la loire est arrivé l'écriture
c'est une autre
forte d'un symbolisme vous avez
participé à la renaissance du breton n'y
a pas de doute mais je dirais quand même
car jacques casillas que dans ce
mouvement breton cette renaissance
bretonne je dirais aussi ce soulèvement
breton veut rire et vous êtes un
personnage à part
je dirais que vous avez tenu beaucoup à
votre indépendance pendant toutes ces
années
ah oui oui je suis resté même presque un
marginal originale qui a des millions de
lecteurs mais moi j'ai toujours gardé
une liberté comme ça on vous en a voulu
parfois rue bruit on a voulu me détacher
dans des ordres à des jeux comme ça j'ai
dit non non je suis le chat qui s'en va
tout seul par les chemins vous voyez des
bois sauvage les ai effectivement
finalement on m'a acceptée on s'est dit
là il est comme ça il n'y a pas moyen de
changer quand il va mourir dans la
pénitence final ce type et moi ça m'a
beaucoup aidé mais finalement autour de
moi un certain nombre de jeunes gens par
exemple des co auteurs bretons j'en ai
rencontré à budapest j'en ai rencontré à
montréal
il gagne gentiment leur vie comme ça et
actuellement il y en a quelques-uns qui
sont vraiment d'excellents compteur
c'est un art le comte pierre jakez
hélias est ce que vous êtes toujours le
cheval d'orgueil
j'essaie de l'être j'essaie de le
demeurer oui c'est à dire j'essaie de ne
pas empiéter sur la liberté des autres
maires aussi que les autres n'empiète
pas sur la vienne j'essaie de ne pas
être quelqu'un qui croit supérieur à ce
qu'il est mais qui ne s'empêche pas de
monter vers quelque chose de plus si
l'on peut dire et c'est ça finalement
parce que l'orgueil chez-nous l'orgueil
en breton si vous voulez c'est cela
consiste à éviter toute prétention il
faut surtout pas être prétentieux et
cela ne vous empêche tout de même pas
d'essayer de gagner un petit peu plus
sans virent aux autres et surtout le
sang bout du rêve ou même
merci pierre jakez hélias et maintenant
nous allons aller à tréhorenteuc sur les
traces de la vj l'art drôle de
personnage qui est venu ici dans les
années 40 un peu en pénitence et l'abbé
jean arrêté en pénitence parce que bon
c'était 1 ab
un peu marginale par exemple il a
accepté de bénir les suicidés par
exemple il a fait faire un chemin de
croix un prisonnier allemand et simone
croix est assez bizarre parce que basse
et céda fée morgane qui lave les pieds
de jésus au lieu que ce soit marie
madeleine et c'est valérie art elle est
allée voir en europe
[Musique]
mais
pour les amoureux de la légende
arthurienne le dos du val sans retour
époque bien des images à quelques
centaines de mètres du val sur la
commune de tréhorenteuc se dresse
attenante à un joli film tiers la plus
petite église du morbihan l'église de
saint onen que l'abbé gillard a restauré
voici quarante ans d'une façon peu
commune mais chez elle on est ici au
québec jpq europe et qui est dédiée à
sainte hélène c'est un petit peu le
coeur de tréhorenteuc ah oui on peut
dire allemand que c'est le coeur de la
commune puisque c'est grâce entre autres
à la vie gillard qui est arrivé ici en
1942 et qui a mélangé l'idée de mélanger
la chrétienté la légende pour rénover
son église qui a fait que maintenant on
peut plus se promener en brocéliande
s'en passer donc ici ça souvent épais
face à ce mélange annoncé c'est unique
au monde a on peut dire c'était ça
d'ailleurs pas toujours été bien vue par
l'évêché
une fois passée la porte de la petite
église les symboles se mêlent les
vitraux les mosaïques les peintures
dessiné par l'abbé gillard relate des
épisodes de la bible à la façon de
légende de la table ronde
[Musique]
joyau de l'église
le grand vitrail parsemez de feuilles de
chêne symbole des druides représente
joseph d'arimathie qui recueille le sang
du christ dans une coupe qui est ici le
graal de part et d'autre de l'hôtel de
vitraux se répondent les douze apôtres
sont attablés autour du graal ils ont
donné le pain et le vin aux chevaliers
de la table ronde
une idée de la baie gillard il n'a
jamais demandé d'argent au diocèse il a
financé par donc sa famille par son bien
personnel
et puis aussi en emmenant les gens en
forêt le racontant les légendes comme
nous on fait maintenant syndicat
d'initiative l'été nouvelle pauvrement
ah oui très modestement ce nous et c'est
doux sucré quand il avait réellement
rien d'autre vous souvenez vous madame
de l'abbé jean ah oui de vienne vous
l'avez bien connu oui bien venir même
bizarre et une pâtes et des charcuteries
les pauvres il est pas tout manger
voulait diaconu quel genre d'homme c'est
être reçu bien gentilles à voyager c'est
une personnalité marquante très
marquante de tréhorenteuc on ne peut pas
quand on a rencontré une fois là-bas
gillard on peut pas ne pas s'en souvenir
regretté par ses fidèles
l'abbé gillard fatigué des critiques
quittera sa paroisse en 1962 le coeur
lié à brocéliande
il y reviendra les mois d'été pour faire
visiter son église aujourd'hui les
cloches de saint onen ne sonne plus que
pour les mariages
mais l'abbé gillard continue d'y vivre
pour l'éternité
[Musique]
au manoir du tertre à paimpont je suis
d'abord venu retrouver
dodik jégo que j'avais rencontré à saint
malo dodik jégou c'est la directrice de
la maison international des poètes et
des écrivains et j'avais été très frappé
par une céramique dodik jégou qui
représentait une scène de la nativité
elle m'a dit que ça avait été illustrée
par pour un compte de deux clientes en
2014 je voudrais que vous me disiez sur
tout
c'est dans le village de pouldreuzic et
dans ce village de pouldreuzic la messe
de noël se faisait toujours le 24
décembre à 6 heures du soir et en même
temps il y avait à la dans la salle des
fêtes de la mairie
l'arbre de noël des écoles laïques donc
c'était les deux fêtes de la chrétienne
et laïque et le père noël était toujours
l'instituteur du village
seulement cette année leur catastrophe
l'instituteur avait été déplacé et
l'instituteur avait été remplacé par une
femme
donc c'était une institutrice et le
problème se pose et qui donc aller faire
le père noël cette année là je ne
pouvais pas de facteur je ne pouvais pas
de le garde champêtre
il était trop vieux que les pas bon donc
le maire elle a quand même trouvé la
directrice de l'école et lui demanda
elle avait un joli dans elle s'appelait
madame voisins il eu du mal à ma sauce
hoisin est-ce que vous pouvez nous
rendent un grand service
est ce que vous pourriez faire le père
noël pour distribuer les objets les
jouets aux enfants de l'école
diot madou et si c'est ça pour vous
rendre service je veux bien on vous
mettra une barbe et la grande au plan
des ans personne ne verra vous avez une
femme
personne ne vous reconnaîtra a dit oui
et puis ils repartirent tous contents ce
disant ça y est on est sauvé c'est
l'institutrice qui va faire le père noël
est chez madame oise là ce soir là il y
avait beaucoup de passage après la mer
voilà le curé qui viennent à trouver et
qui lui dit madame wazin vous avez eu un
enfant il vient trois mois qui est très
beau qui est tout le monde admire
est ce que par hasard vous nous le prg
et aurier pour faire l'enfant jésus de
la crèche de noël puisque vous savez
tous les oyats l'enfant jésus dans cette
crèche
alors madame l'oise à tout fier d'avoir
ces deux rôles de mère de l'enfant jésus
et de père noël était a dit oui tout de
suite
alors on habille à son enfant le lumie
de beaux habits de dans pleins jésus et
on le porte en dans la crèche de
l'église parmi tous les costumes
merveilleux des bigoudènes qui ont des
costumes vous le savez très très beau et
surtout à cette époque là et pour la
fête de noël et tout se passa très bien
madame wazin distribuer les les jouets
aux enfants du village et l'enfant jésus
dormait mais au bout de quelques
[Musique]
minutes enfin au bout de 20 minutes il
se mit à pleurer réveillé par les chants
et surtout ils avaient faim il se mit à
pleurer et à pleurer à crier et plus
personne n'entende et le curé dire ça
mais ce ni les bretons chanter alors vie
qu on allait chercher sa mère qui arriva
en courant avec son costume de père noël
qui ouvrit son costume de père noël
sorti son ca souleva sa barbe et donna à
bois à l'enfant jésus merveilleux c'est
une histoire extraordinaire avoué ce
cannois qui donne qui donne son sein
alors fort jésus c'est une histoire
qu'il peut se passer quand bretagne et
surtout dans le pays bigouden
voilà c'était la réconciliation du
clergé de la laïque voilà par
l'intermédiaire d'une femme père noël
c'est merveilleux et ça nous introduit
très bien je trouve
dodik jégou dans la veillée que nous
allons avoir maintenant avec les
conteurs du manoir du tertre et d'abord
nous allons commencer par patrick ewen
riel s'est levé avant leur premier champ
du maire elle a revêtu
sa robe d'or toute brodée de perles des
pieds nus
d'un rosé elle a dansé jusqu'à vivienne
et elle a entendu chanter cette chanson
je viens par ce flot ce tu me veux tu
peux marcher sous nom
il reste une place à bord de ce bateau
qui vogue vers le pays des jeux reste
qu'une place sa bande ce bateau suivant
m
alors elle a vu
la grande boucle ans
tiré par des signes est sur le pont
quatre jeunes gens qui
il faisait 6
une couronne sur cheveux dans halo font
une étoile des arts jouer leur accorde
le rythme lent des roms j'aime bien
tâche surtout si tu veux tu peux marcher
reste une place ça bonjour à tous
[Musique]
il reste une place à se battre
[Applaudissements]
y a pas on chante et on danse là bas au
delà des flous tard
si tu prends ta chance si tu veux
marcher
non pas au pays des chaînes ne l'a pas
au delà des mers rabat sera notre règle
d'ici c'est déjà bien
[Musique]
ce tu veux tu peux marcher sur l'eau
reste une place à bord de ce bateau qui
forme pure
il disait
depuis sept ans
les flots dans le linéaire et tous les
matins
au bord de l'eau elle attend elle espère
plus une voix plus un appel ces journées
sombres et jeu car il faro
sur le ciel m
deux champs dans la vienne vient pas
chez
si tu me veux tu peux marcher sur non tu
n'as pas pris place avant de ce bateau
qui voguait vers le pdm tu n'as pas pris
place à bord de ce bateau qui vont vers
l'autre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
merci beaucoup très bien alors ça c'est
ce qu'on pourrait appeler un conte
chanté
oui oui c'est un conte chanté oui c'est
tiré de d'un petit conte qui a été écrit
par john tolkien qui est l'auteur du
seigneur des anneaux qui avec le fameux
seigneur des anneaux oui c'est
l'histoire de la petite fille elle qui a
matin de printemps est bien est sorti de
l'enfance
alors patrick ewen pire jakez hélias et
vous ernestine n'auront qui menait de
concoret je voudrais savoir comment vous
inventez vos comptes
comment voulez transformer et comment
vous les transmet les compteurs les plus
connus avec un ou peut-être deux
disciples et quelquefois le disciple
oulai de disciples blu ray chez nous
était de tuberculose et le répertoire
était perdu mais autrement c'était le
disciple qui mettait ça dans sa tête
dans sa mémoire pendant des années et
puis qui repartait sur la route en
actualisant c'est à dire en ajoutant un
certain nombre d'épisodes que l'ancien
compteur n'avait pas eu l'occasion dé m
et c'est comme ça que d'une génération à
l'autre se transmettait les comptes mais
dans vraiment dans dans l'absolu de la
liberté c'est comment ils se sentent
comment ils s'inventent et bien moi je
pense qu'il faut aller au bistrot pour
commencer et puis là et moi en ce qui me
concerne du moins bon puis j'écoute les
gens parler alors des fois c'est
extrêmement difficile parce qu'il faut
bien sûr s'abreuvaient aussi puis une
fois ce sont des choses très difficiles
mais quand on écoute les gens parler et
bien là bas c'est comme ça que les
comptes savante on est et on se retrouve
sur la place de mon de mot à mot là où
j'habite qui s'appelle le men 2 et là on
écoute le j'en parlais il ya toujours
des gens qui ont des choses à raconter
sur autrefois et quand on écoute sont
tous très bien réactualiser sa
aujourd'hui quoi et vous ernestine
heures
vous inventez vos comptes oui j'avais un
pli quelque part c'est à dire que
j'avais beaucoup sur un fait divers un
petit rien donc je fréquente et puis
j'ai beaucoup d'histoires de mon père
qui débutait par un presque rien et
dessus je lève sur 50 blessés ils ont
vraiment une fonction particulière y est
peut-être qu'en bretagne d'ailleurs oui
partout où ils ont pris la suite des
nymphes des auréats des dryades de
l'antiquité qui était non seulement les
protecteurs de l'eau parce que l'eau
était un élément premier il est toujours
d'ailleurs il est même en péril
maintenant techniseal pub et sa recharge
un petit peu nos ressources mais ce qui
est certain aussi c'est que ça pouvait
guérir les rondes qu'on s'adressait aux
nymphes feo lauriad pour guérir
certaines maladies
vous avez déjà fait en est-il de tous
les fontaines ou si je ne suis ni robert
marie quand même mais non non non j'ai
trouvé comme ça et mais c'est pas ça
mais j'avais comment la couvrait sa
bulle une histoire avec saint cloud pour
5 ou ont jeté des clous
oui dans la centaine des comptes sont
bons mais ça évolue
patrick ewen vous avez eu à faire ou ça
vous non moi je pense je prix
s'atténuent où tous les jours qui est le
saint patron de ma commune puisque
jamais une plus lourd ménez qui est la
paroisse de henné ou dans les montagnes
et moi vers seulement quand je pense à
sainté new je laime bien parce que je
vois pas ça du tout comme un saint comme
ça avec un halo autour de sa tête
je vois ça vraiment comme un chef de
guerre un peu médiévale avec une épée et
un bouclier et c'est pour ça qu'ils
opéraient beaucoup de conversion des
repas ce qu'ils m'ont dit
est ce que tu veux te convertir les gens
disaient sinon c'était un coup d'épée je
vois s'atténue humour comme fer monts
d'arrée quoi très rude et sauvage avec
un coeur gros comme ça comme ça
s'appelle la conquête spirituel
directement à cesson que david hayter
batterie suis juste un mot le con ça
n'existerait pas sans le compteur il ya
des chances que oui on marque est
maintenant à la télévision c'est
tellement bien plus le bouton et puis on
reste devant mais ce qui est bien avec
le conteur c'est que celle avantage sur
la télévision je crois que les gens
regardent celui qui raconte l'histoire
et à partir de là les mots font leur
chemin dans la tête des gens et je peux
je pense qu'on peut dire que autant de
personnes sont dans la salle il ya
autant de décors dans leur tête et puis
c'est ça qui fait un peu la richesse du
compte je crois mais ça et puis avec le
feu il faut pas oublier le feu quand il
était un personnage du conte moi je
connais des gens qui ont le chauffage
central chez eux et qu'ils font du feu
de bois dans leur cheminée ce qui prouve
quoi que le chauffage central
ça suffit pour chauffer la maison c'est
donc pas pour chauffer qu'ils allaient
me suit ces morts ce week end et moi
aussi j'ai moi aussi c'est parce que le
feu est vivant
qu'est ce que vous voulez avoir une
imagination quelconque un fantasme
quelconque qui monte en vous devant un
tubes de néon
si aujourd'hui on mettait nos
contemporains affaires 14 km pour venir
verra noël par exemple d'une visite à
leurs cousins à douarnenez vers plozévet
être pouldreuzic à travers une campagne
de buzz où il n'y a absolument aucune
lumière d'ul part vous ne voyez
absolument rien du tout je vous garantis
qu'il verrait des sorcières mais alors
ernestine vous allez aller là bas et
nous raconter un conte le plus court
possible si nous n'avons plus beaucoup
non mais la grèce avait dit très
alléchant
la guerre nos gueules pechos1 guerre
nous y aura de dia ce gros meute en
petits pots à pécho appiah subrenat où
son jeu comme alain vigneault et j'ai
dit bonjour moi j'suis le pechoux fait
que je me sens tout coup je me cormier
sa banlieue est plus lent je n'achète du
le pechoux tu joues seul par k o
ici à tulle d'où d'un coup prince miiaou
le snop est au bout que je te jette dans
la mort au yen autour d'une grosse boîte
juste ioukos tqt de la fière qui n'a
tobu piqué n'en ficon gouly mal peas ou
la vérité c'est tout clocher si bien que
pourquoi est ce aux lèvres du 2 du 2 et
dit à son pechoux à ma liberté mieux que
ça ou toc ou la grenouille en fut
babines et à cause de ça va vanter mal
pechoux tu ne te point est mauvais gars
lui il est aussi ses ânes veut dans la
mort qui fut fort
il y des maps ou google nos vies pour
kakuta sinon
je ne voulais pas de faire demain ma ale
diakhaté ma is of duty world all activé
[Musique]
il faut vingt bonnes minutes et
ernestine laurent pour raconter en gallo
l'histoire de la grenouille et du
pêcheur disons que la fin de l'histoire
c'est que le pêcheur de la grenouille
s'en furent la main dans la main sans
doute la grenouille était telle une
princesse et le pêcheur ne l'a pas vu
assez vite
nous reviendrons en a veillé au manoir
du tertre mais en attendant continuons
donc de flâner sur les sentiers de
grande randonnée de la forêt de
brocéliande
[Musique]
alors entre deux comptes le meilleur
moyen je crois pour flâner en forêt de
brocéliande
c'est le topoguide ici je me trouve un
conte corps est un carrefour de chemin
voyez circuit des korrigans circuit du
château de comper et le topoguide dont
je parle qui est un guide des randonnées
des sentiers de grande randonnée nous
donne des itinéraires suprême de 300
kilomètres c'est formidable et bon des
indications sur la faune la flore la
nature des évidemment tous les repères
tous les témoignages de l'histoire plus
rien ici je me trouve donc à conques
cored en langue celtique ça signifie
valent des druides ovale des faits et
alors le val des faits est tout proche
et monsieur le maire g aubert le seul
maire de concoret vous connaissez très
bien il va sûrement à vol d'oiseau et un
kilomètre
vous avez lu être de pontus qui est
juste au dessus le chevalier noir et la
fontaine de barenton on voit ça dit si
vous y croyez ou la wii vous y croyez
vous vous avez des rapports avec elle
moi je sais pas de temps en temps oui la
deuxième manière expliqué nous on va pas
tout vous dire si ces dites moi vous
raconter tout si non non non c'est vous
qui raconte et raconte et moi comment
les faits ici se sentent bien
s'ils sont pas trop gêné par les
touristes si les gens d'ici croient aux
bacchantes et s'adapte aux touristes ou
si quoi quand on fait ce qu'il faut
aussi croire quand on fait le pouvaient
coteau fleuri la tombe de merlin qu'est
ce que ça veut dire
ce sont des gens qui croient aussi
qu'ils viennent pour diverses raisons
amoureux amoureux de merlin ou amoureux
de la nature ou amour ou les amoureux
simplement parce que c'est un rugby
parce que toujours
bah oui c'est fleury continuellement
toute l'année monsieur le maire moi j'ai
l'impression que vous connaissez
beaucoup de secrets mais que voulez pas
les dix ans la télévision ballon pour
tous ouais est ce que vous avez peur
qu'il arrive quelque chose si vous dites
des secrets comme ça non mais faut mais
regarde quelque chose pour ce pas aussi
le maire de concoret ne veut rien dire
du secret des faits ni des lutins ni les
farfadets ni les korrigans et cetera
mais il a bien tort ses secrets sont
déjà connus en partie parce qu'il ya un
livre vient de sortir en librairie qui
est déjà épuisé presque mais va y avoir
des rééditions n'en doutez pas c'est
l'encyclopédie des lutins de pierre
dubois
bonjour bonjour angers alors est-ce
qu'il y en a ici au château de trécesson
robes alors là faut dire que dans le
coin ça ça grouille déjà il ya la dame
blanche dans le château l'avant à tout
on a le quitta banshee qui apparaît
régulièrement alors les esprits à peu
les esprits là il doit y avoir plein de
crapule synchro pinho temps de d'esprit
aquatique de pierrick de korrigans de
poulpiquet de poules piquant de rio
rennes d'anaheim face et s'est plaint
quoi ils nous écoutent en plus nous ne
sommes pas seuls elles sont peut-être
dans le livre aussi oui des bornes
[Applaudissements]
pourquoi qu'on ne va pas aux lutins sont
des lutins qui viennent à toi et dont
ils ont eu le même temps france oui t'as
vu d'oeil encore la trace du coup de
baguette magique qui sont penchés son
verso quoi il y avait une alliance entre
les hommes et les lutins et l'église a
essayé évidemment de casser c'est cette
alliance a fait donc de ces êtres
charmant des êtres lubrique d être
méchant contre 8,9 et cruel quand même
temps on n'avait pas rencontré sondés se
sentent plus long de la nuit justement
son sont terribles là il a vu qu'il y
avait des galets louette me par exemple
il ya les crocos ordos toutes les
charges grimms alors là cela
effectivement ce sont deux ce sont des
terribles mais il ya les ailes
il ya les jolies petites petit plein se
fait dire non ni les de l'appareil est à
la parisette est adorable en bourse elle
doit donc book
oui oui alors dont tenue couverte de
fleurs elles sont en général très
naturelle comme ça puis se sont quand
même porté sur la gaudriole le assise
ici comme disait brassens du gorille
lalanne un fait est supérieur à la femme
dans l'étreinte
c'est le oui pour ça il faut il faut les
attirer pour faire des petits cadeaux
lorsqu'on se promène dans la nature par
exemple il faut laisser des petits dés
du tabac une des des fleurs si son
audience de finale
oui toujours et à ce moment là elle
s'approche elle vienne est ce que tu dis
là montrent que ton nom cyclopède il
n'est pas fait pour les enfants ou en
tout cas pas seulement pour les enfants
oui parce que les enfants tu as pu le
constater les enfants ont besoin de ces
les gens ils ont besoin de ces histoires
et comme on ne raconte plus il ya plus
de grands parents il ya plus de papy de
mamie de grand-père de grand père il ya
que le troisième âge et encore ils
veulent y semences très souvent ravaler
la façade donc ils ne veulent plus
raconter ses histoires parce qu'ils ont
l'impression donc ce n'est pas dans le
coup donc ils veulent montrer qu'ils
préfèrent le rock et les enfants en fait
non en ont besoin ils vont le chercher
où ils peuvent alors ils vont chercher à
travers les rues de fantaisie dans les
jeux vidéo au cinéma dans les rues dans
les mines jeu mais alors ce qui est
regrettable c'est quelquefois bien quand
ils vont le chercher dans des dents des
produits
comme on dit intelligent beau poétique
oui mais tu penses que ce serait mieux
si les parents et les grands parents
voilà comptait il faut que là ça voilà
il faut que les laits les parents se
rendent compte qu'il ya patrimoine
merveilleux fantastique qui se tourne à
nouveau vers ce patrimoine versées
compte et qui le qu'il offre moi je vois
les enfants par exemple même s'ils ne
comprennent pas tout ils sont attirés
ils sont attirés par le para par les
airs par les faits si les parents au
souffle à nouveau sur les braises qui
pour l'instant sont ne soit pas
complètement morte
mais il suffirait de peu de choses pour
que le brasier serait en flammes de
l'histoire est merveilleux merci pierre
dubois je vais suivre son conseil
je vais m trèfles à quatre feuilles dans
ma chaussure gauche pour essayer
d'apercevoir des lutins faut d'abord que
je trouve le trèfle à quatre feuilles
mais je vais au val sans retour il a
assez c'est une autre histoire une
histoire de 110 ou non
alors
et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais quel diable at il pu mettre le feu
à la forêt de brocéliande quatre fois en
14 ans et la dernière fois c'était en
septembre 90 440 hectares de bois
détruit ici et le val sans retour
devenait la forêt pétrifiée le val sans
retour c'était là où morgan et les fait
emprisonner les chevaliers infidèle
malgré l'intervention des canadairs
malgré les 350 pompiers qui sont
intervenus à ce moment là en septembre
90 ça a été un véritable désastre
alors bien sûr on a nettoyé on a
commencé à reboiser avec des mécènes
avec des associations et avec des
volontaires et des enfants des écoles
notamment et le val sans retour devient
maintenant bon quelque chose qu'on peut
revisiter chaque été mais la forêt de
brocéliande c'est renaître de ses
cendres
merlin l'enchanteur y veille
certainement est en tout cas on le prie
à la veillée
[Musique]
et la merveille est avec nous au manoir
du tertre merlin endormi est-ce que
je trouvais extraordinaire cette statue
ses sculptures c'est que merlin
l'enchanteur endormi à ses racines dans
sa tête c'est ça je ne servais ah c'est
vous qui avez fait c'était ben oui
d'habitude je te tutoie je te tutoie
labatut turion nous tutoyons alors cette
sculpture bon dieu mais tu as mis un
certain temps à la concevoir à finir oui
hélas ses racines dans sa tête que je
répète c'est un un enracinement dans le
dans le spirituel dont dans l'aérien oui
pour moi merlin c'est ça c'est à la fois
c'est l'homme des bois c'est le fou des
bois aussi et puis c'est un
endormissement que tout le monde
regrette mais que lui noix graines porte
puisque il a une espèce de de sommeil
avec un sourire un peu comme les
bouddhas avec une illumination intérieur
je pense que c'est ça son sommeil à
merlin ses illuminations intérieures qui
lui fait larguer le monde tu t'arrêtes
il se réveille et d'ailleurs comme
arthur j'espère qu'il va se réveiller et
que je le verrai un peu comme l'autre
qui attend que les volcans ce réveillon
chez nous là mais moi j'espère que
berlin va se réveiller que arthur va
arriver oui alors tu as fait les
beaux-arts tu as fait ce statut tu
chantes tu es tu transmets de la
tradition en chantant mais la tradition
je vais vous parler avec le père jacques
hélias on parle toujours de la tradition
orale contre ont semé mais elle s'écrit
aussi des traditions et aussi elle
s'invente
oui elle s'écrie elle s'invente alors la
question se pose de savoir s'il faut
arrêter la tradition en l'écrivant
et d'autre part il faut tout de même que
l'on conserve les traces de cette
civilisation orale puisque bien entendu
le compte qui est vraiment l'expression
majeur de la tradition s'exprime il
était une fois ça signifie qu'il n'ya
pas de passé il n'y a pas de présent il
n'y a pas de futur c'est un c'est un
espèce de cordon sans fin 1
je voulais bien à ce livre de gilles
servat vous saviez vous avez lu la
naissance d'arcturus j'ai lu
échange d'arcturus parce que ça moi j'ai
été passionné par ce roman on l'appelle
comme ça je sais pas que oui c'est un
roman tout voilà sont passionnés par ce
que j'ai trouvé une histoire totalement
nouvelle j'étais pris par cette histoire
de d'arcturus qui descendent de je ne
sais quelle planète pour moi c'est comme
ça que je l'aimé et qui combat le nerf
d'une c'est à dire en fait la maison
c'était du monde et qui doit traverser
des épreuves épouvantable pour ça c'est
paru aux éditions kornog à morlaix 1986
ça existe toujours c'est sa cuisine
édition elle est en forme comme ouais
alors là vous avez inventé quelque chose
qui me tue à inventer quelque chose oui
enfin je suis je suis reparti du mythe
du roi arthur justement et toutes ces
rapports entre arcturus l'étoile
arcturus qui est qui et qu'elle a la
queue de l'ours et puis artus qui veut
dire l'ours aussi enfin ya tout un un
mythe de l'ours qui est très très
profond et qui va très loin
et chez les celtes en particulier qui
disent que les dieux viennent du nord
est là la grande constellation d'arte à
la grande ourse qui est qui s'appelait
andard cas chez les gaulois et qui veut
dire la grande ourse enfin bon il ya
tout une chose de l'ours comme ça et
qu'on retrouve dans leur roi arthur qui
est très forte
et moi je suis parti là dessus avec cet
enfant arcturus qui naît sur une planète
qui s'appelle bray de sel premier c'est
l'histoire de ses parents
et là je vais partir un mois en irlande
parce que j'ai besoin de calme pour
écrire la suite là bientôt il faut
écrire la suite moins qu'on l'attend
alors ça va être la jeunesse d'arcturus
là après alors voilà on est dit beaucoup
l'histoire nouvelle peut-être aussi je
n'ai pas lu ses deux livres d'herbe la
guerre des fines des guerriers des fines
et ça c'est ce sont les éduque des
éditions artus ici à la gacilly va
seules deux maisons d'édition d'agassi
et vous voilà donc la ville attend de
lui qu'il est difficile de faire
plusieurs maisons d'édition mais je
crois aussi que en bretagne on est une
des rares maisons d'édition avoir comme
point fixe comme étoile du nord
justement ce monde celtique ce domaine
celtique et on cherche à l'illustré à
travers le passé
les guerriers de fines c'est cette
rencontre qui a changé le destin de
l'irlande entre les troupes de guerriers
chasseurs qui était un peu les les
maîtres de l'irlande c'est elle et les
soldats si vous voulez qu'ils qui est
qu'ils étaient les serviteurs des duos
roi et qui servait à maintenir une
certaine paix sociale dans a traversé
ces tribus qui ces clans qui avait pour
habitude quand même de nous passer un
dernier clin et michel cazenave a écrit
réécrit l'histoire de ces guerriers et
de leur rencontre avec patrick
c'est à dire que nous sommes là à la
jonction si vous voulez de deux mondes
et avec la particularité irlandais c'est
que le christianisme arrivant un
tribunal peut être une saint patrick
saint patrick n'a pas effacé l'ancienne
irlande
au contraire c'est c'est eh scripps et
les phillies ont consigné par écrit ce
qui était la tradition orale et vous
voyez qu'on passe facilement de 2,2 ceux
du conte à la à l'écrit de de l'oral à
l'écrit puisque la en irlande a eu lieu
ce miracle qui a fait qu'on a tout
conservé du vieux monde en partie
conservée parce que vous savez les
druides les druides et les
les moines avaient quand même pas tout à
fait les mêmes lumière sur le monde mais
est né là un christianisme tout à fait
particulier et rendons grâce aux druides
parce que il eu dans le silence
cette durée c'est cet héritage a été
transmis en insistant sur le côté de
l'homme et de la nature puisque ce qui
peut-être caractérise l'enseignement des
druides c'est cette permanence des
éléments de de la mer l'océan ce monde
de mélange qui est à mon avis la spree
celtique et les petits peut à nouveau
nous parler aujourd'hui à travers le
vent à travers la forêt
[Musique]
et
oui
brocéliande et l'irlande c'est les deux
fragments d'âme au monde
c'est deux univers comme ça un peu
brocéliande et est une île vous savez ça
n'est pas ça n'est pas du tout une terre
les anciens cette allée chercher leur le
renseignement de les îles les il avait
plein de vertus une vertu pédagogique
une vertu mythologique une vertu qui
l'enchanté d'éternité la fondation du
monde celtique prend toujours comme base
ces gens venus d'ille inconnu au nord du
monde au nord du monde
c'est ce que disait gilles tout à
l'heure avec arturus c'est-à-dire
l'aller l'origine de polaire où le
régime sud polaire origines hypothétique
bien sûr c'est pas avec les sectes on
n'est jamais dans le domaine de
l'histoire ou de la géographie on est
donc à nous deux mais non violent j'ai
du mythe
voilà pour eux les dieux venaient du
nord c'est le mythe
je crois que contrairement aux romains
les celtes ont transformé leur histoire
en mythe alors que les romands ont
transformé leurs mythes en histoire
c'est complètement différent
c'est là où il ya de monde qui vivent
ici qui sont antinomiques et il y en a
un qui a massacré d'hôtes évidemment et
voilà ça nous a permis au cours de cette
émission de parler de ses éditions artus
qui publie une partie de la mémoire
cette essence et maisons d'édition rats
et bien peut-être que cette mémoire se
perdrait alors on va terminer bien sûr
sur un compte et sur un conte de noël
dire jakez hélias vous allez bien nous
dire ça ah ouais ben oui pourquoi pas
puisque êtes vous seul vous approche de
noël
peut-être serait-il bon de parler de la
bûche de noël qui n'est pas une
pâtisserie jeu c'est une belle bûche que
l'on faisait sécher pendant à peu près
six mois parce qu'elle devait servir
pour la nuit de noël mais on ne la
faisait brûler qu'à moitié
pour ceux qui étaient un peu avare un
tiers et le reste on le mettait dans un
fonds de la cheminée parce que elle
était réputée garantir contre l'orage et
surtout le tonnerre alors il veille à
belleu vieille dame
une vieille dame qui était absolument
imprégné 17
de cette vérité pour l1 et qui mettait
soigneusement cette bûche de côté et une
fois il était dans son champ en train de
tricoter et tout à coup l'orage s'est
levé il y a eu ses aiguilles et qui ont
lancé des éclairs bleus alors elle a
ramassé tout ça et elle est rentrée à
toute allure avec sa vache à la maison
pour allumer le feu dans sa bûche avec
les quatre allumettes qu'elle avait et
le tonnerre est tombé sur la maison et
le fond de la cheville et s'est écarté
il ya une crevasse énorme qui s'est fait
on a vu derrière le jardin potager qui
fumaient et puis là-bas lors la
malheureuse était en train d'essayer de
te de lubasa but plus beau proposer de
contre carrer l'orage et un moment donné
la bûche s'est enflammé et le front de
la cheminée s'est refermé le front de la
cheville et ses refrains et tout est
rentré dans la paix voilà l'histoire de
la bûche de noël telle que vous la
raconter dans l'éventail d'art et
d'ailleurs et si ce n'est pas la vérité
c'est que la vérité à tort en quittant
la forêt de brocéliande
ce que nous espérons c'est que nous vous
avons donné envie de conter des
histoires aux petits comme aux grands
et peut-être de puiser votre imagination
dans les livres ils ont été nombreux que
nous avons présentées au cours de cette
émission où serons-nous samedi prochain
alors là attendez le calendrier est un
peu compliquée samedi prochain 26
décembre à 14h55
ce sera la rediffusion de notre émission
sur saint malo le 9 janvier ce sera le
meilleur de ce que nous avons produit
déjà en pays de loire et en bretagne
c'est ce qu'on appelle le best-of dans
notre jargon un clin d'oeil au fond sur
nos flânerie et puis le 16 janvier où
serons-nous et bien rendez vous comme
d'habitude de 13 heures à 14 heures à
saint nazaire à samedi
[Musique]